[Music]
john in sunnyvale california welcome to
the ramsay show
hey dave how are you doing better than i
deserve man what's up
good uh i just uh proposed and got
engaged this past saturday to my fiance
congratulations when's the wedding
uh i think we want to schedule for three
months so basically either the beginning
of october or the very end of september
love it cool good for you getting a move
on
yeah we're going to be sprinting for the
next several weeks
um okay so my question is um
so she has student loan debt 60k i have
student loan debt
34k and then i have another
personal loan from a friend for 15 000.
my fiance currently has
16 000. we'll come up with some more
money over the next few months to fund
the wedding we'll probably
try to keep it like five thousand but
i'm wondering should she
just throw that toward her student loan
debt and bring in less
into the marriage or can we hang on to
it so we can just completely wipe out my
15 000
personal loans what do you think
doesn't matter they both got to go
yeah and so you know you're going to
throw it at one or the other
within the next three months and it's
not going to change the outcome very
much whichever direction you go
um yeah it's probably emotionally
cleaner for her to throw her money
at her debt uh because one of the things
when you get married
is is it's emotionally uh
i mean let's pretend that you were
deeply in debt and she had no debt and a
big pile of money
and then you get married and she pays
off all your debt because we've joined
accounts and joined our lives the way we
should have
that always feels weird when you're
doing it you know what i'm saying
right i do yeah yeah it's you need to do
it it's the right thing to do to learn
to combine your lives
but it's a normal thing for that to feel
weird and so for her to
reach over with money she had and put it
on what was your debt
now is our debt feels a little weirder
probably than just chunking it onto hers
it really doesn't matter though what's
your health what's your income what's
her income
uh i think she's in the 50 000 range and
i'm at 65.
okay so you have 120 000 income give or
take
115 000 income and um
so you know you just look at that and
say
how quickly are we going to knock this
whole thing out probably within
18 months two years somewhere in there
you should be 100
debt free and so it's not going to
matter which way you go
um there's not a i probably would go
ahead and both of you start
once you've got your wedding budget set
aside both of you just start with your
own plans
and then combine them in october after
the marriage
and uh hold on i'm gonna send you a copy
of the total money makeover to guide you
through that
and that'll be our wedding gift to you
guys and congratulations